when I was growing up in Texas
academy-award night was the biggest
night of the year
my whole family would line up and from
the television with a big bowl of
popcorn our eyes were as wide as saucers
watching all those wonderful movie stars
well it's still that way for me and it's
an honor for me to be here tonight the
five nominees for Best Performance by an
actor in a leading role are Warren
Beatty
you can go
court Lancaster
this is going to be a tough one and the
winner is Henry Fonda accepting the
award for mr. Henry from Golden Pond is
his daughter Jane Fonda
Oh dad I'm so happy I'm proud for you
my father didn't really believe that
this was going to happen but he told me
a while back that if it did he wanted
his wife Shirley to accept the award for
him but Shirley wanted to be with him
tonight as is her way and so I'm here
and first and foremost I want to thank
on behalf of my father the members of
the Academy who voted to give him this
award I know that he's watching right
now and I know that he's very very
honored and very happy and surprised and
I'll bet when he heard it just now I bet
he said hey ain't I lucky as though luck
had anything to do with it I know also
that he has tremendous respect for the
other actors that were nominated and has
always felt a little strange about these
things these competitions because it's
like comparing apples and oranges and he
feels very proud to have been among such
a wonderful group and I know that he
feels that he would never have won this
if it hadn't been for Katharine Hepburn
and if on Golden Pond is one of the
highlights of his life one of the main
reasons is because of her having a
chance to work with her and to become
her friend and I know that one of the
other reasons that he feels the film was
so special is because of the quality of
the crew every one of them many of whose
talents have been recognized tonight in
the nominations and the wonderful cast
Dougie McKeon Dabney Coleman Bill Anto
me
he's a proud father the man who pulled
us all together our producer Bruce
Gilbert he is my father is so happy he
feels so fortunate to have been able to
play the role of Norman Thayer a
character that he loves a lot and
understands very well and for this he'd
like to thank the sensitive man who
wrote the words who's already been
honored tonight Ernest Thompson and for
the tremendous talent and guidance of
our director Marc Riedel he's very very
grateful
we all became like a family during the
filming and we sort of stayed together
since people call him up and stay in
touch and come to visit him and so it's
like we've stayed a family and it's made
my father very very happy and he wants
to thank Marble Arch and Universal for
their support of the movie on Golden
Pond he also feels very lucky to have
been able to spend the summer in such a
beautiful part of our country northern
New Hampshire and he wants to thank all
the people there who were so friendly
and and welcoming to us and he was very
happy and so was I and are we to have
had our two families together the
Hayden's and the Fonda's on the
beautiful shores of that of that Lake so
that we could get to know each other
even more
he wishes my brother Peter were here
tonight but Peter is somewhere in the
jungles of the Philippines in front of a
camera right now like a good Fonda and I
know that lastly but really first he is
thanking Shirley Fonda who has been his
loving support for 17 years who he calls
his Rock of Gibraltar I think she's his
fo fair dad me and all the grandchildren
are coming over with it right away